welcome back everybody we are here with
Hannah waningham and Reeves God give it
up
so that was a look at Reed in the new
Fifth and final season of The Marvelous
Mrs maisel you can see it on Prime video
so thank you so much for hosting our
game you are thankful or you nailed it I
had a great time
yeah I like it yeah I'm an open book I
got it me too my mom doesn't love it so
it's in playing a host on marvelous Mrs
maisel to help prepare for this job
it was a great experience it really was
I got to do research in a way that I I
hadn't done before I mean I always
research whatever character I'm doing a
bit to try to get inside the head yeah
of that type of person but this was so
specific and I grew up you know my
formative years were the 90s so the the
the talk show scene between Conan yeah
and I think some of the very best of
David Letterman yeah you know Jay Leno
and yes prime those were my Knights as a
kid yeah I revered them and I thought it
was just magical what hosts do and I
never thought in a million years I would
ever be anything I would pursue and then
I got to play a bit of a host my
character morphed into a host on Veep
yeah uh where I played this total
what's your fun characters to play right
that seems like a more fun character
yeah it's the best yeah and he played a
host on CBS and was really great because
it was very
satirical how we sort of approached it
and then when this came up on maisel
which is just an incredible show so
beautifully written and beautifully shot
they said they wanted to sort of explore
the sky kind of like a young Johnny
Carson and I was like oh wow that's
really interesting to me it was just so
fun to play in that space But then also
play The Duality of what it's like when
this guy who I'm making a career out of
playing jerks which I don't know what
that says but what it's like when they
yell cut what is he like when he goes
home what does he like with his writing
staff what is he like with Midge who she
she comes on they sort of they start to
work together in a bit of way I don't
want to give too much of it away but it
was just great to sort of feel those
those
switches flip in between the different
personalities that they sort of has to
present one to the camera one to the
audience one to America one to his staff
you just made acting sound really cool
because I love research yeah and I love
I love all the development that goes
into it yeah it's exciting but even if a
character is like like you're saying not
particularly nice or they have this
about them you have to fall in love with
all aspects of them
to give them somebody else exactly I
think yeah
so exciting yeah you made it really
really exciting so wait we don't want to
be rude but we had some of Hannah's ice
cream earlier so we wanted to offer you
some just sitting oh my God don't
offering the one I was going out
just in case you wanted to try it I'm
Southern I know right he's like where
are we in this snow this is oh my God
yes wow you're having biscuits with the
baskets with the boss just try it out
just try it on you can leave it here if
you'd want you don't have to oh damn
that's good yeah okay it's kind of like
shortbread ice cream it's like Comfort
oh it's the short it's the shortbread
from the show yeah yeah that's what it
tastes like I never had it okay so I
heard that you now have I want you to
have food in your mouth when I ask this
next question I heard that you now have
a bad habit when you're out with your
kids what is it oh oh in my mouth what's
wrong with your mouth that's not a
sentence you hear every day
I swear a lot oh me too I have a filthy
milk me too look waitress thank you
right yeah I was a weight look people
they make you mad and darn it doesn't
cover it yeah like yeah not in this town
yeah what is your do you have a role
with your kids though
well it's morphed over the years so my
kids are almost eight and just turned
five like I tried the swear jar for a
while oh my God that's gonna get rich it
filled up so fast yeah that I was just
using it to like tip any delivery person
that came to the house this is not what
the swear jar is for yeah or it was like
you know Tooth Fairy money yeah and so I
realized all right that's not gonna work
it's not the deterrent that I need what
really sort of brought it home is uh I
was driving with my son Conrad and
someone ran out in front of the car
and I screamed like oh my God you bleep
and bleep yeah and then everything was
fine I kept on driving and I hear this
little voice from the back of data
what's a bleep and bleep oh and I was
like oh don't tell Mom yeah don't tell
Mom this or something you know Daddy got
angry and he's like oh okay and then
maybe two days later the exact same
thing happened again someone like
someone on a bike went right in front of
the car oh my God the exact same exploit
is you believe and believe and then
Conrad again it's like um get it there's
those words again I'm like yeah son yeah
really really sorry about that then
maybe a week later I'm outside at the
grill I'm having a good time I'm
grilling up some food and our younger
son was was uh an infant and my wife
comes out and she's tired and she's
bouncing the baby she's like I just want
you to know what your son said he what
he said I want to kiss my baby brother I
want to kiss that bleep and bleep
[Applause]
so I've had to rein it back in a little
bit and now my kids think it's a joke
they're like you're doing it again Dad
okay look I tell my kids that they can
curse when they pay their bills you have
to earn being this trashy
I was like
do whatever you want be as class as if
you want when you're older but like
right now you can't do it because I'm
like I'm not gonna just alter I'm not
like I don't curse that much in front of
them but like every now and then I'll
slip up and then they'll be like oh and
I'm like no no no no don't even talk
about it my daughter has no hope coming
from theater she's got a right potty
mouth for a mother terrible yeah but
they need to see all sides yeah I'm just
trying to show you all sizes
all right we need another commercial
break everybody but you can see the
final season of The Marvelous Mrs maisel
Right Now on Prime video
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]